all right venom let there be carnage
it's out you've all seen it right well i
suppose if you're gonna see it you've
seen it by now which isn't even
necessarily true i'm gonna go ahead and
give you that spoiler warning right now
if you haven't seen venom let there be
carnage or you somehow avoided the
mid-credits scene that's floating around
youtube probably shouldn't watch this
and i'm gonna go ahead and say that
you've been warned that's the spoiler
warning because that's the spoiler right
i should call this venom let there be
carnage so let's talk about that mig
credit sync that's why i played it down
so much in my review it's like yeah make
credit scene it's good you should stay
for it because i wanted to be like holy
[ __ ] that mid credits scene it's wow if
there's it made the movie actually i was
like oh the movie and then walked out of
theater like yeah that mid credit scene
though that made the movie i say that in
my spoiler free review people watching
me like
so spider-man you're saying spider-man
right
because that's what that means you're
gonna get that excited for anything else
i kind of had to play that down before i
get to that there are other things worth
talking about in the spoiler territory
you know shriek gets smashed and crushed
to death by a bell
that happens maybe she lived because you
know the rule unless you see the body
they're not dead but that's some pretty
heavy iron falling from some pretty high
altitude creating some pretty intense
velocity which creates immense pounds of
pressure and that landed on her so i'm
gonna say edge might be dead also
carnage spins around like the tasmanian
devil spins around and creates a tornado
vortex
that happens too this is me talking
actually one of the spoilers that i
wanted to talk about i think i recorded
myself talking about it and editing i
was like let's not talk about that uh
was how cletus cassidy and the carnage
symbiote they weren't working together
you know they didn't have that synergy
they didn't have symbiosis all starts
when shriek screams and carnage like
shut your mouth so anyhow there are some
scenes in here involving shriek where
cletus cassie is like dude i'm a good
boyfriend stop you're hurting her so
they didn't have that symbiosis it's not
like the two of them would bond so
closely that he doesn't use the term we
he uses the term i
you know
comic book [ __ ] which is a really funny
thing that it's like both of these
movies kind of gloss over that the fact
that him saying we is a very important
thing which i get it sounds like a
mundane detail but it's not a mundane
detail it's a very important detail
eddie brock venom they say we because
they're not bonded as one unit eddie
brock's able to keep that symbiote at
bay it's like no no you're using my body
i'm kind of the boss here but we can
work together we can both get what we
want which in the movies the venom
symbiote doesn't get what he wants he
can't eat brains kind of like he was
promised at the end of the first movie
so i get there's going to be tension
which looks like it's story based but
more feels like the writers being like
that's rated our content and we just
can't have that and the last movie broke
a billion dollars and it was pg-13 we're
not changing up the formula so sorry no
brain meals but carnage bonds and he
says i because carnage is like i don't
even give a [ __ ] we're both on the same
page yeah let's kill people i am carnage
because that's what i make it's like
watching the movie you wouldn't know
that but there's always a very important
thing between the two characters an
important distinction just kind of does
a flyby so in the end of this movie
venom the symbiote they're all sitting
around on vacay and eddie brock's like
hey show me a glimpse of what you've
seen and experienced in the universe and
venom's like all right but it might melt
your brain but here we go and then you
see this ripple there's like
this light ripple happen from the
horizon and it hits them it looks like
they're in another place feels like
they're in another place then on tv you
see jay jonah jamison and he's talking
about oh peter parker aka spider-man's
wanted for murder and while the image of
tom hall and spider-man's on the screen
venom goes up to the tvs like this guy
and he licks he looks to screen while
spider-man's on screen you're like
that's such a venom thing to do granted
tom hall and spider-man still in high
school making that a little creepier
than it needs to be but that's such a
venom thing to do licking the screen so
that's where we are now with it it was
this huge shock i mean you can feel the
whole theory be like oh my god
yeah that's sweet maybe i'm just
projecting because that's what i thought
there's some pretty good implications
some pretty great possibilities that
could happen i mean one we could exist
in a world where it's an alternate
reality an alternate universe so cletus
cassidy could not be dead because he
dies in this movie which is actually
where they saved their f-bomb card and i
love the use of it you know it's like
denim has cletus cassidy by the throat
and he's like i just wanted to be your
friend again showing how the carnage
symbiote is way more hardcore and evil
than cletus cassidy i get we're in this
phase of like well let's understand the
villains but [ __ ] it he's cletus cassidy
you don't need to and while he's giving
his sob story venom just goes ah [ __ ]
this guy eats his head like that that
was funny granted i was immediately met
with the feeling of with cyclitus
cassidy's dead no possibility of maximum
carnage and so that's one possibility is
that cletus cassidy is alive um he can
somehow get the carnage symbiote again
or from his standpoint for the first
time which makes this whole movie feel
like uh it's like a trial run for
carnage if they go that route this could
be the last we ever see in cletus
cassidy i don't know but okay venom
wants to go after spider-man now for
reasons unknown it's i don't know it's
just kind of love at first sight i
suppose but he wants to go after him so
it could be a re-imagining of the black
suit spider-man arc for spider-man in
which case it's like that would have to
be a very spider-man-centric movie if
they're doing the black suit thing with
this spider-man or it's another
spider-man movie after no way home or
maybe it is no way home maybe venom's
going to be in spider-man no way home
but there are already a lot of irons in
that fire already i
i'm already kind of concerned about it
like i'm excited but you know you can't
help but be like a lot of characters a
lot of plot lines a lot of things
happening in that movie so venom will
either be a cameo in that movie like
spider-man was in civil war which
wouldn't really feel so fulfilling for
me so maybe they're just setting up for
another spider-man movie in which
spider-man and venom meet or another
venom movie however they want to do it
regardless the most exciting thing about
it is if venom even latches on
spider-man for a second which again i
could totally see happen for spider-man
gets it like yeah yeah no go away
parasite go away you germ then venom's
like oh that didn't work out i don't
know how they're gonna do it
it could be for a second could be for an
entire movie regardless if the symbiote
goes on spider-man and goes back to
eddie brock it could be a case of oh hey
spider symbol on the chest and i shoot
webs now cause i'm venom and that's what
i do if for nothing else you know that's
part of the round table discussion
because for every movie you have to have
a different looking action figure and
how many times can you have the same
venom looking action figure hot toys has
got to be like dude we gotta change it
up somehow a movie venom with the spider
symbol on the chest that shoots webs
that'll sell like [ __ ] hotcakes
regardless the upcoming spider-man game
the sony ps5 spider-man game that's a
sequel to the ps4 game i got a ps5
remaster but still that game's going to
have venom if i had to place my bets i
would say that's probably going to be a
better telling of spider-man meets venom
than what one of the movies can do plus
it's tony todd voicing venom come on
perfect but i would be more excited if i
didn't feel like it'd be more of the odd
couple with a parasite and then all
right throwing spider-man into the mix
and more odd couple with the parasite it
was a fun surprise for the first movie
but
we we just got more of that with carnage
and i wasn't fulfilled in my review of
this movie i said there are some novels
that i've read that are much more
graphic i wasn't necessarily talking
about graphic novels i was talking about
novels
allow me this is from goblins revenge
which does have carnage in it uh the
book that's the predecessor to this
one's called carnage in new york and
there he ravages a whole penthouse full
of people but there's this one excerpt
that always it stood out to me and i'll
read it for you here um i hate reading
and i jumble words and letters around
and i always hate it when the teacher
was like jeremy read in front of the
class i'm like [ __ ] you too but thank
you let's let's embarrass myself today
but i'll try my best here we go the
setup is uh carnage gets onto a plane he
tried to go in his cletus cass and he
got sniffed out and then boom turns into
carnage talks to the captain he's like
get us in the air captain's like i can't
without clearance so
here's what carnage does after leaving
the cockpit the aisles were crowded with
panic people all rushing to get out of
the door everyone sit down carnage
shouted he waited a moment then walked
towards the door brushing people aside
like so much dust bodies tumbled over
seats and smashed into one another one
man in a gray sweater couldn't get out
of the way quickly enough carnage picked
him up by the head and yanked blood
spurted everywhere carnage held the head
up and looked at the bloody shocked face
as the man's headless body fell into the
sitting position in a seat around the
body people were choking and throwing up
most of them unable to look away this
should do fine carnage said carrying the
head by the hair like it was a suitcase
he moved to the entrance of the plane
and walked a few feet up the jet way to
the corner there he could see the police
at the top where he gave the flight
attendant his ticket the last of the
passengers to get out were just clearing
the door up top carnage waited until
only the police were visible and then
shouted if this jet is not pushed back
in five minutes i'll bring you another
one of these like a bowling ball he
hurled the head up the jet way it rolled
like a football bumping and spinning in
odd ways until it smashed with a
sickening thump into the wall near the
door up top strike carnage said laughing
i forgot how much fun bowling can be
still laughing he moved back into the
plane close that door now he said to the
flight attendant close by he stood and
watched while she did what she was told
prepare to take off i imagine we'll be
leaving soon there's nothing like that
in this movie there are no moments of
sickeningly horrifically violent murder
in which carnage is killing with such
gleeful playful joy and you feel bad
about even watching it where you're like
dude this maniac needs to be stopped so
i just i left the movie feeling
unfulfilled well if it weren't for the
mid credit scene that was actually
really sweet with implications
implication and possibility but i've
seen movies that give you the hope and
possibility of what's to come only to
not really stick the landing of it but
i'll give them the benefit of the doubt
i want to see spider-man and venom clash
then again i wanted to see venom and
carnage clash it's all about how they
executed if for nothing else maybe venom
will get a more comic accurate suit out
of the whole thing all right so venom
let there be carnage and that mid-credit
scene have you seen it what do you think
about it what do you think is coming
whatever you think comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more
[Music]
you